[Applaudissements]
le regarder nous allons prendre notre
prochain appel bonjour bonjour isabelle
bonjour sera garé bonjour comment vous
appelez-vous je m'appelle camille amis
ou en famille j'ai une question d'ordre
sentimental
oui en fait j'ai prévu de me marier dans
quelques jours et en fait j'ai encore
une petite crainte parce que c'est vrai
que c'est une personne qui a été très
coureurs dans son passé j'aurais aimé
savoir être sûr si vraiment et puis il a
oublié de passer là un petit peu au
pouvoir de jupons quoi alors quel est
son prénom alors fait un tabac bab bab à
papa baba de stationner là vraiment
amener nous c'est un vrai coup de fil
donc la première question évidemment est
ce que c'est vraiment du sérieux est ce
que siri n'est pas un petit peu sur tous
les délires là je voulais j'ai demandé
c'est la question que j'ai posée voilà
les réponses des ya quand même quelque
chose de fort entre vous deux
certes que c'était difficile dans le
passé parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de charme qui plaît donc un
énorme et m'en tiens quand même à
pouvoir de séduction qui est assez
important mais je ressemble vous allez
bien vous mariez déjà sur tout ce qui
est important que c'est une relation qui
est durable
c'est surtout ça sérieux c'est du
sérieux
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment je me mettais un peu du
finaliste matthieu delormeau donc j'ai
demandé alors est-ce que ce vautour qui
lui tournent autour tous les soirs est
ce que je dois me méfier et ce qu'il a
ses chances et la question d'après moi
je dors par contre camille il y a un
côté un petit peu possessif aussi chez
vous non en fait je l'avais pas avant
mais il y en a un nouveau qui vient
d'une ancienne société où c'est une
société où il y avait beaucoup de
problèmes
beaucoup de gens un peu un peu simple et
donc en fait une fausse moins sympa
c'est est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
garder l'idée d'inviter justement au
mariage des personnes qui voit la liste
pas draguer ouvertement
non vous ne devez pas vous méfier de lui
pour moi baba il sait exactement ce
qu'il fait et l'engagement qu'il va
prendre avec vous dans quelques jours
donc cette personne n'a aucune chance
avec avec lui quoique mais oui
camille pour moi ça coule de source
[Applaudissements]
on a baissé les yeux
ghellab dit pas que des conneries
parfois en émoi vegas il n'en est rien